[Musique]
ça devient intimidant avec ces grands,
allez d'
accord
tu ne peux pas hésiter si tu hésites
oublie ça tu vas perdre
[Musique]
oh mon Dieu tu as une bête ouais je sais
ouais Amy
c'est une bataille ce n'est pas facile à  attrapez-
les parfois ils vous combattront Je
ne peux pas maîtriser un python de 17 pieds donc je
dois être plus intelligent que les
pythons birmans envahissants de serpents qui peuvent atteindre aussi
longtemps que 18 pieds ont pris le contrôle des
Everglades de Floride sans
prédateurs naturels les pythons  déciment
la faune locale en mangeant de tout, des
lapins et des oiseaux aux Bobcats et même des
cerfs pour brute Je rencontre Amy
Seaweed qui a abandonné sa carrière d'
agent immobilier il y a trois ans pour venir en
Floride et chasser les pythons ouais
[Musique]
[  Musique]
merci d'
accord d'
accord
je pense que nous sommes prêts
[Musique]
salut c'est Amy voyez nous vérifions pour
une enquête sur les pythons à Big Cypress
merci au revoir
nous sommes dans les Everglades occidentales et
c'est l'un des écosystèmes les plus diversifiés
au monde il  c'est vraiment incroyable c'est
les pythons pleins de vie
ne sont pas faciles à trouver et vous
savez que les gens viennent ici en pensant que vous savez
oh c'est les Everglades c'est énorme c'est
incroyable il va y avoir des pythons
partout je vais juste commencer
à traverser le marais et je
vais trouver  des pythons et c'est ce que je
pensais et ce n'est pas du tout comme ça
pas du tout même si les pythons
font des dégâts incroyables parce qu'il
y en a tellement qu'ils sont si
difficiles à trouver qu'il faut trois ans
pour qu'un python atteigne 10 pieds et  il
faut 200 mammifères et oiseaux pour y arriver
,
ces choses vivent pendant 25 ans,
donc je veux dire que c'est beaucoup
de nos animaux indigènes, ils mangeront des rats, des
écureuils, des
lapins, des ratons laveurs, ils mangeront des cerfs Bobcats,
nous avons trouvé un python.  avec une biche et
deux étangs et sont en même temps des
oiseaux les échassiers des
vautours ils mangent tout
littéralement tout et leur nombre
est hors de contrôle car ils
n'ont pas de prédateurs
merci le
python envahissant a commencé sh  dans
les années 80, lorsque les propriétaires d'animaux les relâchaient
illégalement dans les Everglades,
puis en 1992, le problème s'est aggravé
lorsque l'ouragan Andrew a détruit
les installations d'élevage, libérant des centaines de
serpents dans la nature.
pour
sensibiliser le public aux serpents, mais avec une
centaine de milliers de pythons à
l'état sauvage, ils ne peuvent qu'espérer ralentir
leur croissance
J'ai été courtier immobilier ces
13 dernières années dans l'Indiana et
j'ai appris le problème du
python  -semaine de vacances avec mon fiancé pour
venir en Floride voir de quoi il
s'agissait et nous avions un python et j'étais
complètement accro et c'était moins de
deux mois plus tard j'ai juste
tout lâché dans l'Indiana je ne savais pas vraiment
où aller  les chasser, je n'avais pas de
travail, j'ai loué une chambre à un gars sur
Internet,
donc sur le papier, cela ressemblait à la chose la plus stupide
que j'aurais pu faire, mais dans
mon cœur, ça  était la seule chose dans
toute ma vie que je savais sans aucun doute
c'est ce que je suis censé faire
Je rencontre Andre ici ce soir euh pour
chasser ce Levy parce que c'est je veux dire c'est
plus facile d'avoir deux personnes je veux dire il y a
deux côtés de la digue et vous savez que
je ne peux en couvrir qu'un donc j'aime chasser
ce Levy avec quelqu'un d'autre ouais
il y a de meilleurs endroits là-haut
j'y suis allé et j'ai eu
avec Ashley et j'en ai un donc
nous sommes prêts quand vous
ça va, faisons-le,
nous chassons les pythons sur la route la nuit,
donc nous chargeons essentiellement dans un camion et
nous conduisons sur les routes et les digues à
environ cinq miles à l'heure avec toutes nos
lumières à la recherche de pythons et nous
recherchons  pour eux sur les bords des
routes on les cherche on
attend qu'ils traversent les routes
partout où on peut les voir c'est
ça qu'on cherche et puis
tu sors quelle heure ce soir euh je veux dire
quoi qu'il arrive  pensiez-vous comme 1h du matin non je
veux dire d'accord je pense probablement 12
30 ici,
je veux dire selon si nous passons une bonne
nuit, alors vous savez
quand vous conduisez toute la nuit
et vous savez que vous ne trouvez pas un python
toutes les cinq minutes
quand vous le faites, je veux dire que l'adrénaline
vous pompe c'est c'est tellement  excitant
juste là le
voir
non tu n'iras nulle part
ça va être intéressant
ouais il le jette regarde qu'il
ferme
c'est super sombre aussi donc tu peux oh
c'est ce que ouais désolé mon
pote j'aimerais pouvoir t'aider à baiser parce que
je sais que c'est vraiment inconfortable
partout
[Musique]
oh Dieu je l'ai repéré il était si sombre  il
était vraiment difficile de repérer une
étude en 2012 a révélé que les
pythons envahissants étaient probablement responsables du
déclin massif de la population de la faune locale,
y compris les lapins, les renards et les
lynx roux, l'État encourage maintenant le
meurtre de ces pythons par le
public et les entrepreneurs rémunérés bec  Parce qu'ils le
voient comme le meilleur moyen de sauver leurs
animaux indigènes, nous pourrions utiliser ma boîte.
juste en quelque sorte les ramasser en
plein dans le
coma ouais il est lent
ouais il était vraiment
prêt à basculer mais maintenant il ne l'est pas
et c'est notre premier Fin Fun c'était une
nuit
j'aime tous les serpents qui m'ont
fasciné  eux depuis que je suis enfant depuis que mon père
m'a mis dans le ruisseau et m'a appris à
attraper toutes sortes de créatures et pour une
raison quelconque, cette fascination pour les serpents,
vous savez que ça m'accompagne depuis
et les pythons sont juste incroyables
ils '  ils sont magnifiques ils sont absolument
magnifiques wow regarde ce
truc
[Musique]
c'est une lutte incroyable j'aime
les pythons je déteste qu'on doive
les tuer
on doit se débarrasser de ces ces serpents
mais c'est incroyablement dur je  signifie que vous
avez ce grand géant magnifique anim  al
que vous devez poser c'est
déchirant
[Musique]
une fois que nous avons attrapé les serpents et que nous les avons
euthanasiés, je ne veux pas qu'ils
s'enfuient, alors je les écorche, je les fais
tanner professionnellement, puis je les
transforme en produits comme Apple watch
groupe des choses comme ça
pour avoir une très belle peau c'est un peu
c'est beaucoup de travail
je vais commencer par celui-ci
c'est un peu fastidieux c'est un peu dégoûtant
euh ça prend je veux dire ça prend du temps
ça sent bon quand même
[Musique]
celui-là dans ma bouche
tu sais que je me suis en quelque sorte donné
pour mission de trouver comment utiliser autant de
python que possible pour qu'ils ne soient pas
gaspillés tu sais que je ne peux pas je déteste l'
idée  d'entre eux sont simplement jetés dehors
et pas vraiment honorés ou quoi
que ce soit parce que ce n'est pas de leur faute ils sont
ici c'est tellement malheureux que ce n'est pas de leur
faute mais ils doivent y aller
[Musique]
la viande n'est pas très bonne à manger alors vous
connaissez leur  la peau est évidemment belle
et elle fait des produits en cuir incroyables
[Musique]
donc ces peaux h  J'ai été tannée professionnellement
, j'ai donc environ 120
peaux de python ici dans ma maison et avant d'
acheter ce porte-vêtements et vous pouvez voir que
je veux dire qu'elles sont juste épaisses, elles aiment juste
continuer et j'ai même
les plus petites  suspendu à un rack à l'
intérieur, alors oui, j'en ai des tonnes
avant de l'avoir, même si j'avais des
peaux de python sur mon canapé, je les avais dans une
chambre d'amis, je veux dire, je les ai tous
ici, je les ai tous
ici ici
Je veux dire qu'ils sont partout, donc vous avez en
fait des vêtements, ils sont quelque part
là-dedans, vous savez que je ne sais pas oh et j'ai
oublié ça aussi c'est un 14
pieds que j'ai attrapé,
elle pesait 105 livres alors comme en fait je vais
juste
ouais ce n'est même pas le plus gros
que j'ai attrapé mais c'est gros je veux dire
tu sais essaie de lutter contre ça et celui-ci
est celui qui m'a mordu à la main
j'avais en fait le contour des
Jaws sur ma main  de celui-ci,
donc c'est une bouchée de dents acérées comme des rasoirs
et ils peuvent aussi se décrocher
ici, donc n'importe quoi t  chapeau qu'ils peuvent mettre dans
leur bouche ils peuvent manger ce n'est même pas
avec ses mâchoires ouvertes complètement elle pourrait
facilement me manger ils peuvent s'adapter à la tête
ils peuvent s'adapter au corps de n'importe quelle
proie et je serais le dîner si elle  si
elle voulait me manger alors je suis content
qu'elle ne l'ait pas fait et ceux-ci sont toujours d'une netteté remarquable,
je viens juste d'être le premier un peu
là
[Musique]
J'ai attrapé près de 400. c'est beaucoup
de pythons mais c'est  pas même une
fraction de ce qui existe ici, vous savez que
nous avons bien dépassé le point d'éradication,
nous aurons toujours des pythons dans les
Everglades,
cela semble sombre, nous n'avons pas trouvé d'autre
moyen qui soit meilleur que de mettre des
chasseurs là-bas pour les trouver un à la fois  et
ils gagnent
[Musique]
mais vous savez avec chaque python
que nous sortons des Everglades, nous
sauvons la vie de centaines de nos
espèces indigènes et c'est ce que nous
devons faire
jusqu'à ce que nous trouvions quelque chose qui ne le fera pas
avoir un effet néfaste sur le reste de
la faune c'est la meilleure façon
[Musique]